we might be drunk
we might be drunk
as long as we are hanging out you know
we might be drunk raise a glass let's
talk [ __ ] head peeps wrecks and a bit
maybe drunk
we might be drunk
yeah
hey hey folks here we are we might be
drunk we're here we're queer we're we're
are we in the holidays still yeah it's
the holidays christmas time is here
hanukkah time kwanzaa time whatever you
want to call it what's going on we got
godfrey here on the ones and twos the
beard
godfrey do you drink
what do you guys get oh i mean i'm not a
drinker like you guys i don't know my
liquor that well
uh parents
weren't big drinkers but we always had
liquor in the house but they did it
usually for company like yeah but my
company beer my father drank beer yeah
company
yeah uh she drank beer wines and we had
we always had liquor in the house but we
never
my father was always like don't do
that's not good yeah so we never but
then like my sister and my brother's
college that's when they started but
we're not good
no
no
i didn't even drink a college man really
well you were an athlete yeah but still
athletes drink yeah that's true
strawberry but you're a baseball player
right football baseball shortstop field
shortstop in baseball
until high school just from like
literally to high school okay i was
short stop like serious like shortstop
like damn yeah yeah and um yeah baseball
then got into merged into football and
track and field just on some like oh let
me try that right right yeah i'm saying
so yeah i was a big baseball head holy
[ __ ] yeah oh yeah oh my god grier barnes
me yeah grier's in for love of the game
the kevin costner movie he's a big
baseball guy like yeah oh great actor as
well
yeah yeah i was baseball was my thing
like
growing up in the north side of chicago
grew down street not too far from
wrigley field white sox oh cubs cubs
yeah yeah and so what's the difference
between white sox and cubs fans one's on
the north side the others on the south
side is there a beef
and not like yankees and mets
is not as intense but there is like but
i watched the white sox i was like the
socks of chicago i didn't give a [ __ ]
you know yeah and we had harry kerry oh
yeah but harry carey was with the white
sox first uh-huh harry carey was gary
well harry carries was in saint louis
he's from saint louis then he came to
the white sox with hawk harrelson and
then he came to the to the cubs that's
when he got really famous when he was
like with the cubs we were like oh [ __ ]
because he'd be drunk cubs would lose no
one gave a [ __ ] everybody was waiting
for harry kerry his uh seventh inning
stretch to come and sing take me out to
the ball game because he'd be [ __ ] up
yeah they'd be like everybody
we're all like this yeah [ __ ] it we're
getting smoked 11 or nothing we're like
that's the thing about chicago a lot you
stood out we had a lot of horrible teams
for a while but there's always somebody
that stood out if it's sammy sosa it's
you know what i mean it's like joseph
was so likable and then you hear behind
the scenes you're like this dude's like
a sociopath really yeah you see him in
the interview and like i think it's
jeremy sham and the doc is incredible
the espn thing and he's like just admit
you cheated and he's like i don't know
what you're talking about
he's got like bleach white skin now he's
like everything about this
yeah he bleached his skin he's like the
joker now it's crazy so bad really did
you see that
documentary
what are we drinking by the way here the
summer the long is it called long summer
with it's the mark mcguire
and that summer when they were going
against yeah
the home run record you seen the doctor
i saw the social dog i didn't see that
stick is
fantastic baseball was so fun yeah yeah
it's fantastic
oh wait wait wait wait wait wait what
are we drinking a full description here
beard
this is uh
today we're drinking the classic old
man's drink the rusty nail oh
baby rusty nail huh so wow it smells
good scotch and drambuie and a little
wet booty
that's my drink bro the isle of skye
booty
oh the isle of skies
no it's just this is what sidatra
yeah this is uh this was made popular by
the rat pack oh wow
i love the rat pack yeah i read all the
books on the rat pack came out in the
60s it was uh pioneered by the 21 club
let's get together of the guy you think
you came in with luck be the lady
tonight
all right
[Laughter]
this is a pretty good dress it's great
it's just it's subtle it's nice
it's good sweet but see you guys are
drinkers you know you know drinks this
thing's burning my chest
you see how he doesn't even feel it goes
down easy yeah i like it this is nice
it's really nice i have something easier
for you
if you want yeah easier because i feel
the heat i'll drink that one if you want
we gave you the little lady glass too i
like this i like the ice cubes man oh
yeah
i like wrapper this looks like one of
those like commercial shots which yeah
that's perfect you know how you have
food experts right like put fake eyes
this is well he looked like he's a pro
myself
well did you no
you're big enough for me to believe it
that means i'm genuine you know what's
good those uh those decerono on the
rocks that with the michael imperial
he was doing the 1800s
yeah i like those they look so good that
was that i like that dude that's a
horrible liquor by the way decerono
improve imperiale i saw him my buddy uh
babs
was he's a
nigerian actor he just moved he moved to
london a few years ago he's a
uh one of the he's the highest ranked he
was the highest ranked jiu jitsu master
you know in on the eastern seaboard it
was my buddy he used to hang with us me
and artie and all well you got to be
able to fight if your name is babbs
[Laughter]
this is his friend leslie
and he's a fantastic actor
and he did a one uh it was a three-part
three-person show play with imperioli oh
wow it was really good it was like a
taxi cab stand thing it was like a
off-broadway play it was like yeah yeah
yeah that's that's the right guy he's so
new york i love that dude yeah he's a
cool ass dude too man it was really it
was cool to meet him like i was like oh
[ __ ] you used to live with viola davis i
lit my fur
isn't that crazy
my first
my first roommate like when i got here
guys it's so funny because my managers
have passed away
it's like when you're getting you're
like life is true try manage me as if
they passed away
it's it's like my my two okay when i was
in chicago i got this guy named tk
kirkland i know tj
that act
he'll he'll turn the room yeah he's he
he's gangsta hardcore but he's the one
that influenced me to come to new york
really people and people when he talks
they go oh he's [ __ ] lying oh
he doesn't lie he's he sounds you have
you ever heard somebody that's telling
truth but sounds like they're lying he
goes he goes yeah he goes i he stole
eddie murphy's watch what yeah he he
took puffed i think who's credit russell
russell um simmons credit card when he
was 18 19 he was i love this guy charlie
because charlie murphy
you just love people who steal yeah
charlie's a kleptomaniac oh yeah oh yeah
not with jokes or anything but no good
no not definitely not that but he'll
steal like a candy bar
i
because i was a big kleptomaniac in
college same i stole a lot of [ __ ] in
college because we had no dough
you're broke as [ __ ] i went away for
school university of illinois fighting
illini oh yeah
i was a pre-med psych major so
this is what happened our books were
super expensive yeah yeah and you're
like it's a racket what the [ __ ] is this
you know like
college is expensive it's unnecessarily
expensive so i'm like [ __ ] you know so
what we did was my friends were working
at the bookstore
and you know you had people who would
work study
i did library work study my friends did
one worked as a snack shop warm
bookstore so my buddy would be like
listen man
these books are expensive as [ __ ]
this is what we're gonna do my shift is
between blah blah blah blah blah
yeah you know it's cold out so he said
yo bring your coats it's gonna be a
heist and yeah so we would just take
books national lampoon presents ocean's
eleven right yeah yeah
we would take books especially the most
expensive ones yeah the texts that we
didn't wanna and then buy it and then
pay for the smaller the more the cheaper
ones right in other classes but the
science ones we took a bunch of books
because you can sell them back yeah
exactly and you sell them back for
decent money you're you know you're
[ __ ] 18. and you're getting 300 at
the end of the [ __ ] year you're like
words so we would steal and then here's
another thing you got to admit
what we did too was we was like
operation fight the great of this guy
darker and darker that's getting
creepier or creepier that's what i love
about podcasting [ __ ] it let me go for
it let it all out um
operation
finals exams we would go
to like certain dorms or certain
engineering spots and start taking
everybody's books
especially some [ __ ] we didn't like
we go all right and we like calculus the
calculus book was always the best catch
so we'd go yo we're gonna you know we
come to certain like study areas and we
start snatching people's [ __ ] everybody
was doing it yeah we would go to the to
the uh to the merch like you know you
got sweatshirts sure fighting like and
my friend worked there and they had no
cameras oh yeah they never had a
different time so we'd be like yo he and
he'd go to the back yo i'm gonna go find
that that size for you yeah just start
right and he make sure we get stuff for
them
oh we everybody was doing it yeah steal
it the snack shop we had a snack shop we
would go to
yeah there was like now there's cameras
now they got to go like pulp fiction
like if any of you [ __ ] move i'll
shoot every last one
no no no no no no no no no no and this
is before before google i imagine so if
you didn't have a calculus book you
didn't know calculus you couldn't look
it up anywhere isn't that crazy yeah we
used to and it was like it was addicting
i i was getting away i could i was
getting good at stealing i was like man
i'm not even a thief but i love stealing
it was like
i love stealing and then like i had
buddies that got into credit card [ __ ]
oh we did that for a while a lot of
crime in in college man in the in the
frats the fraternities oh yeah man these
[ __ ]
because we okay in illinois we had the
biggest fraternity and sorority system
in there were you
my buddy was my buddy kyle black dude he
joined a white fraternity kappa sigma
and i remember moving him in like is my
buddy from high school and i'm i was
moving him in like moving him in and the
black fraternity dude saw me the omega
you ever heard omega the q-dot oh yeah
i've seen revenge of the nerds
you ever see stomp the yard
so these guys omegas they saw me moving
stuff and he go they're like hey yo man
what yo what the [ __ ] are you doing i go
oh this is my buddy kyle he was one of
those black dudes that didn't he he
always hung around white guys that's ah
that was but but we got one of the good
ones
me and kyle
were friends because that was my buddy
because he related to me because i hung
out with everybody yeah you know i was
always i went to a bunch of rushes yeah
on rush is just free booze it's free
booze and free food so i was because
everybody i was going to be courted oh
it is but i was the black dude me and
kyle were the black dudes that people
wanted in their fraternities right so
they'd be like dude they'd be like this
amen sig ups man we're the best here's
my buddy steve this is my buddy josh yo
man we could have anything we got a
great barbecue man every year we got
this
right
so it was like and i could play my ass
off by the way oh really [ __ ] fanatic
i'm fanta
i was fantastic oh that was the only
thing white people had on
the hockey stack and hockey
sack here's the thing about hacky sack
if you played soccer yeah same [ __ ] it's
the same [ __ ] it's like
i you know my friend minus the weed but
uh yeah
i'm nigerian so
soccer was my first sport is
my uncles they all played so
that you know i knew how to dribble with
my feet you know
and so when i played hacky sack you know
it was not that if other than these
moves yeah i got really good at it but
then you know um it's so funny because
hacky sack is you you throw a hacky sack
to a mexican dude he's like oh oh
that's an african guy
you know anybody can play soccer did you
just you know what i mean so that was
easy hand foot coordination hockey i got
something to tell you all day oh
hockey let me tell you something about
hockey i found this out i found it out
oh you know i just came back from
edmonton okay you guys do edmonton sure
house of cards i've never done that one
yeah you gotta do it
i don't know why for whatever reason
it's one i've done winnipeg i've done
vancouver toronto
montreal i win the tough one it's the
80s and like
80s
i
winnipeg i i want to go i've done when
it's below 40 degrees it's like
they have underground tunnels yes
they get so cold i've done winnipeg a
bunch of times rumors i've done winnipeg
comedy festival i've done winnipeg many
times yeah i just i just i can't do i
just can't be there i'd rather get
pegged
i'd rather get
[Laughter]
you know winning you go into the corny
zone you just go yeah let's do it hey
man
i might need another one of these these
these are friends these are right you go
down easy the dramboo you haven't done
[ __ ] edmonton yet i've never for
whatever reason i know it's an oil town
it's like oh yeah the pig rigs yeah rig
pigs
yeah rig they'll take they'll because um
shout out to uh rick bronson and tammy
yeah they love comedians oh yeah cause
rick was a comedian and he's a fantastic
magician really
i'm telling you he is an amazing
magician a lot of comedians are were
magicians first steve martin woody allen
johnny carson they were all like
magicians first but
yeah they like comedians you have a name
you can do i mean i just realized i
haven't eaten
oh [ __ ] i haven't eaten yet today i'm
going to get this guy a couple of times
yeah that's not going to be good yeah
well i could do one more i'm done well i
could do one lives on empty stomach i'm
gonna tell you something about hockey
real quick yeah that i discovered uh-oh
because i um you know when i i like but
but being in canada a lot i got used to
like watching live hockey but i was
watching hockey with the blackhawks
blackhawks are major to us in chicago
sure everybody watches the blackhawks
black people we we [ __ ] really hardcore
know that we [ __ ] with the black we wear
out as t-shirts we i had mugs
blackhawks are serious all chicago teams
are serious in chicago yeah we support
all our teams
period yeah so it's easy too when you
had the 90s bulls
yeah yeah it's easy to have a couple of
liters no we were we were we were loyal
to our hearts
before chicago's legit chicago to me is
like i have a few cities in america that
are like i'm like these these are cities
i [ __ ] with cities san francisco chicago
i love boston but those are like great
major ones are like chicago philly
philly
oh we all love our teams we all have a
lot of pride in our teams chicago all
the racially tense cities yes are the
best
comedies that's so true it's the truth
philly boston chicago all the angry
cities
detroit that fight over their teams
their [ __ ]
best comedy well attention comedies
tension exactly well you guys have so
many great comics out of chicago you
know oh yeah yeah oh yeah i mean you had
like bernie mac you knew bernie
yeah what
i think he's one of the greats and i
don't think he gets put up he doesn't he
doesn't and it's i think it's because we
know he's great yeah the problem is i
thought we didn't have a chance to see
him do specials
we didn't have specials are what keep
you keep that's like your catalog like
you see carl and carly has like 13
specials yeah you don't understand 18.
it's something crazy right crazy he was
like the first eight i think robert
klein or him were the first hbo guys
yeah and you got
like chris rock he has a catalog of
specials you know
it's fortunately we got this you know
the netflix thing when they're actually
acting properly
giving specials to the right no i'm
saying yeah chappelle did what four in a
year or something he has a he has a
catalog and i i i hope that
specials are like his podcast he's like
we're gonna throw out another one here
exactly it's amazing he just goes i
wanna do a special
i think i need to talk to the gay
community again
just another special i know this is
going to be part two
of me not being homophobic
[Laughter]
chappelle could be in his [ __ ]
underwear in his bathroom and they're
like this i'm doing one out the bathroom
it's gonna be prolific the dropping the
deuce tour yeah
on the toilet everyone's like well that
was brilliant
belle can do whatever [ __ ] he wants i
thought it was just gonna be a piss that
transitioned into a [ __ ]
it was a six and a half hour [ __ ] he
broke the trick's record
but the the hockey thing
yeah i'll tell you i looked it up
because i'm you know me i'm always like
looking up like if black people created
[ __ ] sure to that cause they'll be like
this this man created this i go hmm
my malcolm x goes i don't believe that
[ __ ]
i don't know why i had to do the malcolm
x voice for the eddie murphy 80s voice
man
so i was like dude eddie murphy's dead
on yeah it's but it's the eddie murphy
that was like
the loud black dude when eddie murphy
did the loud black guys
[ __ ] you're right kiss your ass
man i'ma whoop your ass that that you
know he's so good it was so funny that
just makes me feel like that's like my
childhood so it just makes me feel good
dude
i think about seeing the nutty professor
in the theater with my dad and never
seen my dad laugh that hard in my life
eddie murphy i think deserved an oscar
for that thank you because he played
like 10 [ __ ] people and he didn't
play like a cheap ten like i'm like it
wasn't
like a heart man they had fun like a mom
with like a heart something about the
industry it must be something against
the guy against combat it's comedy
it's not that's unfair they don't [ __ ]
with comedians at the oscars but that's
so unfair because but he should have won
for dream girls
i think there's a jealousy of
actors are jealous of us
i'm serious i think there's a jealousy
of being able to make people laugh like
that there's a jealousy we also live
much more recklessly than actually no no
but comedy's harder than that
i'm not saying that what i'm saying is i
think actors see that we can just be
free like we can just do this [ __ ] right
there's our way over the script that's
true we're just making our [ __ ] yeah
that's true they're going to be wanting
to be funny so badly though
it's like it's like comedians that want
to be musicians and musicians want to be
comedians right john mayer but i really
ever see an actor on like a late night
talk show you rarely like them more
who's true
you see an actor on like fallon or like
whatever show and you rarely like them
more like you like them more when
they're the other person and that must
be [ __ ] up like yeah yeah you love me
when i'm pretending only but when an
actor is funny now that goes a long way
because john malkovich
man yeah
yeah he's so damn funny because he knows
everybody knows malkovich for his
serious face right another chicago guy
ah
yeah brilliant acceptance theater yeah
they they um they like him for it
because when he was on conan
one of the funniest interviews
i have never seen him on i never did
anything dude i just re-watched rounders
that's a great [ __ ] great movie his
accent made me laugh
though thing about rounders though is
that his horrible russian accent is that
he goes you have to make that money i
need money you better give money that
[ __ ] was so terrible
[Laughter]
everyone starts clapping on set and he
leans over the table to matt damon
that's what matt damon has said
interviewing he leans over the table he
goes
i really don't know what they're
clapping at i'm a pretty horrible actor
wow
he goes i made money
it [ __ ] was making me laugh
that [ __ ] was hilarious i love him kevin
spacey also great on interviews yeah he
was very good he can imitate people yeah
really funny
kevin [ __ ] yeah
yeah right keaton was a stand-up michael
michael keaton is great enough yeah
keaton's dope as [ __ ] um
uh what was he gonna say
ah i just had what was i was talking
about uh oh hockey no no no eddie murphy
this happens a lot in this
yeah malkovich so malkovich is talking
of conan and conan yeah i mean out of
all of them is my favorite yeah and he's
like this is laughing going so you said
you're like really good at stuff he goes
yes i am i'm amazing at lead wrestling
he told us like what
leg wrestling no one's beating me in leg
right leg wrestling he goes i would like
to challenge you in leg wrestling conan
can we pull this up matt can you pull up
the malkovich leg wrestling leg
wrestling
uh conan
it's [ __ ] hysterical i missed that
one and everybody knows because people
are intimidated by malkovich so he's
just like he uses that as the comment
yeah he goes yeah i'm very good at
i would like to
is that it yep
[Applause]
host conan so conan really is the best
he's fantastic yeah but that's malkovich
was he's a funny dude yeah i like that
because he doesn't he did he doesn't
laugh and he just tells joe he's just
being very funny yeah with that with
that facial expressity it's really it's
really cool but i think people are
jealous of comedians but
we do host all of it you gotta that's i
think that's why you know it's like
billy crystal christmas but not anymore
they're kind of getting rid of that
they're scared
they're survey scared everybody good for
your face i know i love it i think we
can all agree he [ __ ] killed it he
heard it he and and because people are
so fascinated with british accents we're
so we're so amazing even when these
british people aren't funny we just
think
and then
really yeah it's like this can you
believe this
no
obama
you believe in god it's like this yeah
so how about this
[ __ ] off
really you are an incredible
impressionist you're doing great
for that no well you're not you know
when no one no one calls you an
impressionist but you do incredible
impressions they're not bad
yeah
how much work do you put into it
not a lot like i knew norm mcdonald what
yeah i knew norm how well do you know
jordan [ __ ] with me hard cause norm i
remember i would catch norm it would be
either
bearded drunk norm
whoa or he'd be you know or be or shaved
because he's a handsome guy yeah [ __ ] he
was a hamster shaved very handsome
yeah or i'd get a shave drunk norm or
shaved or
gained a little weight yeah because he
was always in and out yeah you know and
then i remember one time i was at the
laugh factory
i come upstairs
he goes got me man
yeah man wow you're awesome on stage man
yeah he's like yeah listen uh you ever
done snl
i go i go now i said you ever done it
like he wouldn't have heard about it
like you've ever done snl man all the
voices and now your voice i was [ __ ]
awesome and i go i go now i got rejected
by snl three times really oh yeah man i
i auditioned we got to talk about this
oh yeah i auditioned we'll tell this
server but we want to hear snl next okay
yeah he goes yeah yeah he should do snow
maybe he's trying out uh yeah and i go
uh
i um i tried they just kind of rejected
me he goes ah [ __ ] him
he goes they hate me yeah they hate me
nbc they [ __ ] hate me yeah he's
that's what he said but man you're
talented keep it up yeah he he [ __ ]
with me hard michael richards [ __ ] with
me hard whoa
man i got stories michael richards
would remember when he snapped i heard
you having him
remember when he snapped remember when
he snapped
but i saw that
that's what got me into comedy before he
did that i saw him i heard he walks into
cancelled anonymous meetings like kramer
[Laughter]
i saw him do that to an old lady i
wasn't i was hosting at the laugh
factory because slapped on her yeah i i
was hosting the laugh factory and this
is when i was by coastal and um
you know we're bi
i i i went i i he was on stage he gets
on i bring him up they know michael
richardson people losing their [ __ ]
because it's [ __ ] kramer sure and he
gets on stage
he's doing that [ __ ] for like five
minutes everybody's like this
they're looking at him like all right
[ __ ] yeah and he runs into like
the wall he's like oh whoa yeah
do an issue and everyone's like get to
the [ __ ] joke
because the applause was huge and then
they were like all right now that's the
one thing i love about comedy
comedy becomes the celebrity it's like
okay great now can you do the art form
we're here for example he was a
brilliant comic actor but it doesn't
necessarily translate to standards he
was on a show called fridays i remember
that yeah it was fridays was a was a
sketch comedy thing on abc and then nene
went into [ __ ] seinfeld yeah yeah so
and and he was in uhf too the weird
album yeah yeah and then
stand up man that's why i stand up
that's why i love it i go stand up is so
wonderful that it's going to filter the
[ __ ] that aren't doing it right
they're going it's going to get you tony
woods said
the joke gods are going to get you
shouted
the joke guys that's an underrated guy
and so um
he he's on there
doing some weird [ __ ] and this old lady
goes you were better you're funnier on
seinfeld
he goes you [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] oh
yeah he's snapped [ __ ] losing his
[ __ ] and he leaves he just walks off
yeah walks off and they're like god you
got to come back in you got to come back
in i go what the [ __ ] happened wow you
just [ __ ] snapped and all you see is
the mic just dangling
yeah they should bring back seinfeld but
this time kramer's got an anger problem
right and jerry's like you gotta stop
saying the n-word
little did michael order to know that
old lady put a hex on him
years later i was and what i was what's
funny is i was with mike
a week before he did the end word rant
sure that was like the first taste of
like what has kind of come to be known
as cancer culture yeah yeah yeah i was
there i was i was of this
whatever this type of cancer culture of
course yeah and i was with
i was with him a week before he snapped
and then cnn called me
and i went on the anderson cooper show
but
was on he was on assignment it was john
roberts who's on fox now and he
interviewed me
and i was me and him and i was on yeah
see i've always wanted to be on a cnn
desk and i was and i was interviewing me
about what do you think was is cooper
cool
i never i didn't mean cooper i was john
i roberts you meant you were doing a
cooper interview on his job no it was
anderson cooper's show but john was
taking his place because he was on
assignment wow i was like [ __ ] but john
roberts is pretty well known and so i
was like he goes so what did you think
about that i said i mean he snapped
i've seen him snap on other people like
that he's called people [ __ ] and all
that and he did that so weird shock
value
i you know he's a really strange dude
he's right because when i would talk to
him one time i was he was sitting on the
street you know the stairs of the laugh
yeah and i go i come around he goes hey
hey i want to talk to you man i love
your stage presence man yeah wow oh man
it was [ __ ] great but i was like
thanks man you know i'm talking to him
but it was weird yeah but i'm like
he's not a guy yeah he's an odd
[ __ ] so he doesn't know how to
handle the stand-up world he [ __ ] up
but he i know he's not going around
hating black people right
a lot of these guys i think it's a money
grab you have the fame from elsewhere
and your agents are like you can make a
lot of money doing stand-up build and
act sure but they don't really have the
tools to do it so they don't have the
humility to fail in this way they failed
under the standards of course right like
no one can question his greatness as an
actor but yeah it's a different type of
failure and you need humility and you
have to have humility every day you've
got a bomb the show is different even
though you know oh these jokes kill we
don't know until you get on stage you
really don't know until you go what's up
everybody you don't know it's a risk
every time you risk every time but
you're like but i'm good enough where
i've my my percentages
it's not it's not really probability
probability happens with these [ __ ]
bums that think they can just get up
there and i'll just get drunk just
[ __ ] dude
there's a formula to this [ __ ]
[ __ ] there's if there's a real
formula because you've tested it all
over the world and you go right i'm
gonna do this joke damn it hit it yeah
there's a real [ __ ] formula because
the magic of stand up too is you can
have the words the cadence the rhythm
but it might not work in this room for
some reason and you have to figure out
why it's amazing it's so weird by the
years you put in it you can go okay that
didn't work watch me do this yes i've
seen that you ever seen that you're you
ever been on stage and you go oh my god
i'm experienced i actually did i did the
joke didn't work but i was able to do
that i called an audible
i get surprised sometimes when like a
riffle work and then you're like oh yeah
i've been doing this every night for a
long time i mean you finally got it it's
muscle memory it's like you're never
watching like walt frazier call game and
a player's off he's like he's aiming his
shot you're like yeah you're thinking
about it just trust the repetition yeah
trust the muscle memory yes you're gonna
make it work if you just go with it even
if you even if you're bombing a couple
riffs you're gonna get him eventually
but that's from doing reps
reps
and you know and other community what
you have tips go on a lot that's it
there's no magic trick you go on a lot a
lot long you go [ __ ]
damn there yo wow if i didn't have the
reps i wouldn't have known what to do
right with that it's like when i was in
martial arts i did martial arts for 10
years out here i did hopkido 10 years
that's the stephen cigal [ __ ] right
that's almost it's a it's a cousin to
steven seagal [ __ ] it's like it's all
like grab wrist bone break and all that
[ __ ]
you can fight you're you're in great
shape yeah i don't listen he can fight
no come on you dress like an out of work
ninja
there's no way you can't fight i've seen
you kick i've seen you move you're in
great shape you're shut up he shops at
the store but understand he's just like
we're in a [ __ ] cop movie together
after i [ __ ] everybody up you good yeah
[Music]
you got to teach me your move yeah yeah
i i never tire those buddy cop movies i
don't know
there's something about them like the
two guys who can't get along yeah like
whether it be rush hour or 48 hours as
long as it's it's all about the
execution of the people in it yeah it's
all about the people in it like jeremy
piven he's been doing he's he's he's in
the comedy world he calls well yeah he
goes god needs some help got to pick
your brain so great that he calls you
god and he's from chicago
chicago guy too his theater guy from
chicago his mom created theater in
chicago and he's like this uh and i hop
as soon as he became a comic i became
his friend yeah yeah yeah just like bro
you got to do some cigars man got to
pick your brain you know and he's a
really great actor yeah he's incredible
yeah stand up he's getting there
it's but it's like it's hard to start
once you're famous years
i give him props for even doing this
[ __ ] he's well do you think he's making
an insane money on the road isn't that
yeah you get happy i give you problems
but also you know
it's a it is a money grab too right
comedy that's what i love about comedy
because comedy shows up and goes you
didn't put your time in sure and i'm
gonna let people know you haven't yet
but he's such he he's acting like a
comedian okay he's such a good actor
he's acting like a media it's not
intrinsic yet it's more surfacy right
right right it's like when an actor
plays a comedian in a movie and you're
like i can i know you're a good actor i
know dustin hoffman's a brilliant actor
you're still an actor you're still an
actor you did lenny yeah when he did
lenny i um i did a uh indie film one
time
is elijah wood
so i'm hanging out with elijah wood
giving him tips he was in la it was i
needed a comic in it he's a comedian in
it how many movies do they can make
about like august just cast the comments
i don't know why they don't just play
[ __ ] we can play this this is how
much they're jealous of comedians they
won't even let you play a comedian
i'm telling you wow they're they're that
jealous that they
wanted to do it because i heard they
though i've heard that forever is that
ever going to happen no of that i heard
that too oh my god i think he would be
good actually because it's going to be
lenny henry i think he's a british you
know black people are playing us now
it's a
yeah idris elba plays yeah all black
british people snowfall black dudes
british oh really yeah he's he's british
he i was watching his interview i love
it herself i heard the new western is
great yeah i liked it i liked it is it
good dion cole's in it it's very
stylized very tarantino-esque it is
i mean i love luther i think he's
awesome yeah he's uh
but he plays american accents uh on the
office he was hilarious i mean that's
the thing too he's he gets comedy too
he used to work with the dora caroline's
interest
yeah he was terrified is that right yeah
get out of that guy's too hot to be
terrible he was a d and he was dj dj i
heard he's a great guy he i never met
him i've seen him from afar but i never
like met the guy you know yeah yeah yeah
but yeah um they're gonna do a guy named
sir lenny henry i guess he's he's a
famous comedian guy and
they're considering him to do richard
pryor which is that benny henry this guy
right here they want him
to be
richard pryor i heard mike epps was in
the running mike epps was supposed to be
because mike called me
to help him with inflections
to help him with the prior voice yeah
because i could do prior that's a game
changer you get that role that's a game
changer you have to do it right though
you really really sure you don't want to
i mean i mean look what jamie foxx did
with ray i mean that's like murdered ray
like jamie foxx is the [ __ ] great
yeah he really failed it like perfect
like because he's a pianist also trained
yeah he can play piano solo
that's going to be a
you got to really come with the [ __ ]
there's layers to that [ __ ] because nick
cannon wanted to do it
there's too many jews on set
you can't focus you can't have you can't
have a not good stand-up play prior you
can have an actor but you can have a bad
standard but you got to get a good point
you got to get out you [ __ ] is
crazy jack
i don't give a [ __ ] god
you have to have the yeah man and i'm
i'm just saying [ __ ] [ __ ] are [ __ ]
up man that you gotta it has to be
levels has anybody seen you know you got
to be able to and there's the breathing
that's some funny [ __ ] this is good
wow that's incredible mike called me
because i thought he was about to do it
and he said i mean i need like a voice
like a coach like can you help me out
because you can do them and i said
i was like you got to pay me
[ __ ]
i'm joking but yeah but no the hand
movement is perfect then it went away
i don't know what's going on with it
because the wife the one wife his white
wife that he married you know he had
eight different otherwise short hair
yeah she's like hardcore i think
jennifer she's like really
kind of kind of guarding the [ __ ]
property right so it's kind of tough so
i don't know it's going back and forth
different people are trying to play them
i don't know so much goes into these
decisions but i mean there's a lot of
[ __ ] [ __ ] that goes on a lot of egos i
think of course
well they did a pull it up matt they did
a sam kinnison movie and it looked it
looked rough i mean i'm sure you could
find the same chemistry
i don't know if it got any play but
there was a trailer for the sam kinnison
guy
matt are you there i was just watching
sam kinnison like his first
letterman appearance oh it's real great
i mean talk about a game changer it goes
into the crowd like everything that
you've never seen the fourth wall yeah
that's that preaching he had
that's him no that's not it that's not
the real thing like a dog that's really
cool
that's really good no that would be good
chris rock says he changed the format of
stand up really really did he really did
he was very conversational
um at least this [ __ ] his long
jacket's cause he's terrible
yeah yeah he looks like
two two funny things about him one
preacher
who was in a car accident his family
[ __ ] his head up became a stand-up
roseanne was just like a housewife got
no car accident started doing stand-up
wow something weird about knocks coming
off or not coming back in really exactly
that's crazy about the car crash [ __ ]
head out of the car we might be drunk
and sponsored by better help better help
is the therapy for the 21st century
better help is a professional therapy
and it's all online what's standing in
the way of you achieving your goals
figure it out with better help
look i never did therapy he brought it
up to me i gave it a shot changed my
life everybody should do it it's like
going to the gym for your emotions and
your brain and you all got baggage you
all got history
try it give it a whirl take a shot who
cares you're scared that's what it is
sack up puss
try some therapy it's all remote do it
from the comfort and privacy your own
home flexible schedule video phone calls
at your convenience
get a good match they'll put you in a
licensed therapist who is right for you
that's the most important part of there
but you need to find someone who you
feel like you can talk to who gets you
it's fast you sign up you can start
talking to therapists in less than 30 in
less than 48 hours no waiting around
it's affordable and now you can send
messages to your therapist at any time
they'll get back to you in between
sessions wow that's amazing
don't like your person switch anytime
you want for free they make it easy
trust me it helps to have someone
outside of your world to talk to it's
easy to schedule affordable it won't
take a load off your shoulders over a
million people have already taken charge
of their mental health join them tell
them how sammy better help has a special
offer
often
god i'm off today what the hell your
offender
better help has a special offer for our
listeners visit betterhelp.com
drunk
perfect for 10 off your first month
that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p-com
slash drunk for 10 off your first month
betterhelp.com sign up for betterhelp to
start living a happier life today hell
yeah
i will say about the kramer thing
there it is
hold on let's see who it is oh wow
that's pretty good that's not bad
that's nice let's hear the scream
i want you to do me a favor this is
pretty good the voice is pretty good
[Music]
i want you to do one thing for me
remember this face you're ready
good screen this was fantastic
i remembered it yeah
what actor is that
oh really that is amazing but you know
that's pretty actually impressive you
nailed that screen fantastic man good
for him i remember not being here that
was very good no that was years ago that
was me oh wow
what is it
dan fogler well done folks what about
also what about the guy that's doing the
robin williams what there's something
like that
i mean let the [ __ ] corpse get
[ __ ] cold before they do these movies
yeah same birthday robin williams
did you know
oh yeah i did shows with him he came to
the cellar a few times i met him at the
seller once we chat for a long time and
he couldn't have been cooler that 98
photo that you see in the cellar i was
there whoa i think i was hosting that
day yep who would have been who were
those any of those legends that were
like was bernie mac really cool to you
as a young person he took me under his
ring man i have i have a i have a
there's a thing mit bernie mac had a hbo
show called midnight mac before all this
other [ __ ] in chicago where he had his
band he had a band um and he had his
macaronis his dancers and he you know
that's what he did in his open mic shows
he had a band he would bring us up me
dion cole corey holcomb all of us and
and um i did a sketch with him it's on
youtube i did a sketch with bernie i'm
24. yeah and bernie was like and he was
like god i want you to do a sketch you
know i want you to do a sketch because
you know you talk you talk real problem
[ __ ] you know and this sketch is a it's
a [ __ ] agent you know
come to the hallway you're going to meet
me at the [ __ ] bar and do that
you know you talk real problem [ __ ] and
i need that [ __ ] you know but
college [ __ ] incredible you know so i
was like all right and that's all i
think you look up midnight mac maybe
i think it should be
midnight mac is it
is that it he doesn't have a ton of
specials but if you want to see
quintessential bernie mac murdering he's
got the last set and kings of comedy you
know it's a deal hugely
uh steve harvey or whatever but he
murders that thing yeah it's an
incredible set him and steve harvey have
um were rivals oh really they didn't
like each other they didn't like each
other um because it was like
they were fighting because bernie um
steve harvey couldn't follow
um bernie of course so he had to host
because bernie was murdering
and
they were like i know gq magazine i
interviewed bernie saying yo i heard you
got you um i heard you are you upset at
steve harvey is he are you upset at him
he goes he's not good enough to make me
upset oh he said that [ __ ] cause steve
hated on him so much there's um do you
know anthony
um oh god we're still with steve do you
know steve harvey at all or no yes i
know steve chicago chicago no he's
cleveland but he always but he always
came through chicago okay i would see
him at this we had a club called was he
was he a good dude to you he was cool he
actually because i was in a comedy team
for a year it was godfrey and alexander
a guy i was with big tall dude and he
was [ __ ] up because he would he
didn't because a duo was hard yeah and i
was writing all the sketches and then i
was in the hallway and i was pissed off
and steve came out steve was like yo
what's up what's up why you what's what
you mad about it's like i'm just my my
partner he's not he's not remembering
his lines he's always up there drunk and
[ __ ] and i remember he goes he goes
steve goes how much money are you
getting i was like i'm getting about
we're getting like 100 bucks is i first
started he goes
you tired of splitting that [ __ ] yeah
he's like cut his ass wow
i got a photo with steve that day what
are you talking about
yeah steve yeah and then i opened that's
when i opened up for jim carrey what yes
yes
yeah yeah
this is too much gold i'm sorry 1995 i
opened up for jim carrey at illinois
institute of technology because my
friend was an engineer and she was
running the student activity she goes
you want to open up for jim carrey i
said are you [ __ ] kidding me it's one
of my favorites jim carrey's a big
influence on me i mean that's after dumb
and dumber the math this is 95. this was
like yeah and it was like he was really
coming he was starting to get like
really big and i opened up for him i
have a photo with him and we were in a
basement like he was me him and harlan
and harlem still remembers me from that
day and i go that's how i became good
friends with him and i remember he was
the nicest dude because his camera
members managers asked me hey man you're
a big jim carrey passing [ __ ] yeah he
goes just trying to make sure that your
style is not the same he's like oh no
i'm totally not i go he's but a big
influence on me he goes we just want to
check because we don't want same [ __ ]
and i respected that because we want to
make sure everybody's doing their that's
why harlan's so different than jim right
even though they're both canadian i go
no i don't so i i i harland is kind of
underappreciated he's really funny i
think he's a really funny guy he's
really hey scooter what's your name
oh what's your name okay that's cool are
you from outer space
i love it he's fantastic yeah man but
anthony griffin is that that's anthony
griffin okay
what did jim say do you remember any of
the conversations
no he was just talking about what he's
doing next and stuff and you know like
how long he's been doing it if i
remember he was just really it was just
me and him
basement man i got a photo with him got
it just me and him oh yeah here it is
yup keep moving towards the end
moving towards the end well we can't
play i'm scared of you [ __ ] no
no i can't do that but it's so funny so
good
i think
keep going
what year you think we're in here
it's got a couple million views over
here
i i you know what i'll maybe some other
time i'll show you that because if i
look at my phone
i always because you know on youtube it
marks your stuff down when you're
looking at stuff yeah videos let me see
if i can get this real quick all right
good night mac
watch this mid i don't even know he had
a show on hbo how did i miss that yeah
it was like a few episodes and then
it um
yeah
it's midnight mac with bernie mac part
one
part one and it's at
hold on
oh [ __ ] he knows a huge burning
and go back watch this how nervous were
you
there's just one minor change okay
the show needs a little more edge
you know hip-hop
gangster
that's it
gangster
i'm like this sell out agent right
let me explain something to you
mr hbo
[Laughter]
and hello not changing it for you
or anybody else you understand me
do you understand me
see i'm bringing the back to the front
you want some flavor
you just take the show the way it is
oh you make the call
he coached me yeah burn you drive a hard
bargain
hey drive a hardback
[Music]
yeah
that's my proof of i know bernie that's
amazing yeah bernie really was really
nice to me he took me under his wing and
[ __ ] like that legend you know who loves
bernie mac seinfeld it's one of his
favorite comics he won't shut up about
bernie mac really loves bernie mac wow
and seinfeld i got i was i'm in comedian
that's right i'm in two scenes man i've
seen that a million times ago well you
got enough he's like i'm gonna do the
road now yeah you got enough yeah time
felt like
saw me do what did you see me do this
was the funniest [ __ ] when i was kept i
came back from egypt and i was did this
whole thing about
uh whether i should ride a camel or ride
a horse because they give you a choice
at the pyramids oh yeah they say you
want horse or the camel and i was like
[ __ ] and the camel i'm doing all this
[ __ ] about the camel and he had seen me
and then he goes hey and then i see him
some weeks later and he goes hey man
i've been wanting to talk to you for a
minute but so we sit and we talk at the
at the olive tree for like an hour whoa
[Music]
oh yeah
and jim norton is
looking at me like this
i hate you he was jealous you like this
i hate you look at you what are you
obi-wan kenobi he was just he just kept
saying you bugged me look at you your
eager face yeah he just kept sitting
back there and i'm just watching jim
going
i love it yeah but that's yeah that's um
i got a lot of [ __ ] stories man it's
like you once you stay around you know
you guys you guys are collecting you're
collecting stories yeah you know uh jay
leno sandler you met i met yeah i don't
know him i don't know him but sandler my
story with sandler is when he came he
was doing comedy again and we were at
the comic strip comic strip was dope
and he was what happened to the comic
strip man it got it it was dope it was
dope as [ __ ] it got corny me and papa
were comic strip guys i love tommy me
papa judah friedland we were all yeah
uptown dudes like yeah before i
it was
you judah and tom papa that lineup let's
kill him yeah it was me
old school yeah it was all of us
at emacio it was just awesome i remember
mace yeah
killer and lucian was alive boy lucian
was mean as [ __ ] um
but it was all of us burr it was all of
us i saw
at uh at the comic show when i was in
high school i went to a show it was like
kevin brennan
yeah it was all of us it's a great show
and so
i don't know richie tinkin who was a
nice guy i knew you know richie tinkin
yeah i knew him before his voice was
when he had a regular voice yeah tinking
and lucian and that was when it was cool
man and then i don't know what the [ __ ]
happened thank you it's either i don't
know if it's managed i don't know
something changed one day you've got to
care so much to keep a comedy club you
have to care you have to keep it's a
culture you can't be distant from it you
have to be really in it and you really
have to see that's why sd is so and
they're so hands-on right but that's
what keeps it decent yeah even though
there has leaked there's been some wack
[ __ ] leaking into the cellar oh yeah but
but it's still it's still it's still a
good club it's still good [ __ ] yeah
there's still going to be no
even with issues it's the best club it's
still the best club because of the
hands-on yeah see if if maddie were
there liz is so honest
and you need that you need that kind of
you need that [ __ ] you need it because
when manny was here alive manny you seen
the photo of manny yep norm's dad
oh [ __ ] that dude didn't play he was he
was funny as [ __ ] norm is scary because
noah sounds like his father it's right
it's scary no one will be joking i go
you're just you're doing exactly like
your father he literally immediately
he's a good man he's a good man i
remember the new york times with that
story on him they tried to peg him and
stuff and i was like man yeah you don't
know how good a dude this is he's really
a good dude he has his things where you
like [ __ ] know him but every person
has their things everybody does you're
running a business he's
he is a good man and he's a very and he
does right by the staff and by the
comments yeah and that's the most and
that's hard to do well you like it his
father ain't there his pops didn't give
a [ __ ] how you felt i remember his
father would do this if someone's on
stage
him and este would speak in a hebrew
they'd be like
and then manny would go like this to me
get the [ __ ] cane and you're like
get him off whoa
man he was funny though he had jokes
manny was [ __ ] funny well they said
he would hold court was it colin
and he was patrice
quarters you missed that time of this
year yes it was do you miss like patrice
andrews
geraldo patrice
boss it was all of us just all of us
ripping on each other artie
uh ian edwards dina it was all of us
ripping each other to shreds yeah
dogging each other jim norton i mean we
we murder and then talking about
politics and race and we'd be talking
about real [ __ ] yeah because geraldo was
brilliant he's a harvard lawyer
brilliant
brilliant
attempt we everybody was graduat uh
judah has a degree in film from nyu um
showed his attell so does i mean i have
a degree in psychology i was and we all
everybody could talk you know and he
would bring politicians we had
professional talkers right yes he would
bring politicians man he brought
politicians to the table
i mean like famous [ __ ] came to
the table to talk to us and he would
take us to the martin luther king
celebration he was part of the corps he
was part of the
manny's uh um noam's dad was on the the
board of the martin luther king
foundation so we would go i met hank
aaron laura bush yeah are you having
karen have the biggest hands ever man
hank was like how you doing i was like
god damn it all right all right man
[ __ ] like yeah so baseball is really
like
we've lost something great and i don't
mean to sound like old america here but
like baseball was so fast
and it's kind of it's lost a little bit
well corporate it's corporate now and
people don't stick and it's like
football nobody sticks with their teams
everybody knows where the money is which
i don't blame them because football nfl
is horribly wrong it's it's horribly
mine it's like no different than boxing
it's just but you go for the money which
i don't blame i like gruden
[Laughter]
no but when they here's what here's when
you know the nfl really [ __ ] up
they're literally giving these players
ctv
[ __ ]
that was a hurt man i mean and like but
you're giving these players cte you're
killing them they're getting blackouts
yeah there's no long-term health
coverage and then you're [ __ ] getting
mad at them for doing end zone dances
like are you [ __ ] kidding me yeah
they're dancing yeah silly what if he
just got his cte results
[Laughter]
the table was this bastion of thoughts
and
provoking and all that and now it's so
weird like i said [ __ ] at the table and
somebody was whoa watch the language i'm
like oh we gotta go and it's not even
like a pc thing or like whatever or
offended things it's like what are you
doing we were talking about you're going
to talk about my wife yeah jesus is
correct yeah and it's
[ __ ] up because
what we used to do too man i man
what we used to do too is like we'd go
down like say voss goes down on stage
and we'd all come down and stand in the
doorway and wait for him to do some wack
[ __ ] we go
man
and we'd walk past to the bathroom and
on purpose to get distracted yeah keith
would go mackie does that to me mackie
still maggie does to me all the time
he'll see me on stage and i'll keep
doing this or he'll do this
he'll give me the kill give me middle
fingers yeah they kept us sharp we
dogged each other we'd be like oh and
when when norton would be like oh colin
you're cancer legs i'm sick of your
cancer like why are you crossing those
cancer legs you piece of [ __ ] and kind
of be like i'm finished i'm [ __ ]
finished
it was great it was great it was almost
like a ball team
we would disagree
and [ __ ] would get heated i remember man
i remember this [ __ ]
9 11.
when 9 11 happened they had opened up
after about a week they started opening
we started doing shows for
the workers you know we did what we
would do i did a theater where all the
the workers they were dusted they had
the dust on them still oh my god we had
to do shows yeah man we need to do shows
and i remember it was me marin
chris rock
de paulo what was this said i gave it a
ground zero it was pretty bad
cory ellie we all did a show
and i remember
mitch feytell
mitch feitel went on stage and was doing
his little little boy [ __ ] you know he
goes oh my god oh my goodness
that [ __ ]
and we were at the table
and we went upstairs
and we're at the table and mitch feitel
comes on
and goes hey what's up guys and mitch is
cool i'm like hey what's up and nick
goes really is that that's what the [ __ ]
you doing on stage
acting like a little [ __ ] kid when
people are [ __ ]
dead bodies
wow what the [ __ ] wrong with he just
snaps on him he goes olive the
apologists yeah blacks out
i go i'm like
he goes he goes dude this there's you
know we got bombed right did you know
that do you have any jokes on that
you're not even [ __ ] talk he goes i
don't need to talk about that i'm not
i'm giving he's going the escapist right
i was like man i was like yo nick leave
me there that's what he does man the
[ __ ] you talk about that guy it was
still [ __ ] he goes
he goes what the [ __ ] was that he's like
he was like it's [ __ ] you know
you're [ __ ] grown man he just gets he
just snaps yeah yeah that's happened
before stuff like that happens every
once in a while yeah you know what i
mean yeah yeah it was uh
yeah harsher remember already lang sat
down like two years ago at the club
before cove and he was like what are you
doing you guys are like complimenting
each other this is weird yeah yeah and
and it's like i don't like sitting at
those tables really depending on who it
is it's like you're afraid like yeah i
don't know who's gonna take [ __ ] for
right
yeah we used to [ __ ] on you like patrice
would be waiting
like jabba the hutt he'd be sitting
waiting and you see the waitress chained
to his leg
[Laughter]
and he'd be sitting and you'd walk in
and he's just you're about to get you
got to get [ __ ] up i know and he'd be
like this
yeah
yo what the [ __ ] are you wearing you
know right and we but that's what we did
well you kept each other in check now we
talk about safe spaces and all that [ __ ]
i'm like i'm scared of you i'm scared of
you rattling me out or tweeting or
whatever like you're scary yeah i'm just
gonna say uh a offensive word or a joke
yeah it's sad that's and that's what
that's why a lot of the comedy for the
ones that are all pc it's weak weak [ __ ]
well it's important to have like i'm not
saying that like we all bullied be
careless but like it's nice offensive
exactly it's nice to have an anything
ghost table yeah it's nice to have like
one place you know you can kind of just
say you can take risks that are that are
never malicious
but are you know that might walk a line
of decency yes yes there's something
exciting about that that right that even
like in a prohibition type vibe that
exists yes if we lose it everywhere if
we lose it even at a comedy club then
it's just lost it's lost exactly it's
not fun and people say how is this
affecting you
on stage i go what i'm like i haven't
changed [ __ ] same same here but i'm not
calling people the f word
right i'm still doing those jokes but
i'm
and there's nothing wrong with okay you
know what instead of there i'll tweak it
and go here that's cool but i'm not
losing the integrity of the joke saying
i'm going in exactly
and i do i did lgbt [ __ ] all day this
weekend i was doing lgbi's like i have
this joke ryko the lgbtq they're bored
they're bored
because gay my my gay friends
gay people like to be noticed let's be
real the culture is very
it's flashy it's very flashy it's very
like hey i'm here right we know look at
uh miranda yeah
i love that that [ __ ] makes me laugh
yeah it's great we love better they like
they don't like these these are so fun
and the fact that they're being
normalized now that you got your rights
now you're being normalized no one cares
now that's that's that's pissing them
off interesting so they go let's go part
of their identity was the story they're
like we used to be like oh now let's go
[ __ ] with pronouns we're bored
so i talk about that and it's working
but i'm like you guys are bored i'm not
dogging the lgbt i'm saying you guys
it was kind of better it's an
observational journey
when you guys came we knew you were here
yeah you loved it you were loud now no
one gives a [ __ ] right now and now
you're upset like damn this is not cool
we're not that's a funny angle well it's
also not even you're you're kind of
criticizing from within you're not
saying i don't like you you're saying
here's a funny observation right i mean
that's it right if they're if they want
to be normalized
okay we should be able to make fun of
you now yeah
yes you're welcome to
society right right what do you got to
make up your mind your special interests
when you get to the [ __ ] comedy club
but then you want to be normalized
outside that's not how it works
we get jokes from normalized society
right that's what we get we get jokes
from the life we live yeah so you sh if
you want to be treated like human beings
i should be able to joke about you from
a good place but there's a lot of funny
[ __ ] in the gay community because gay
people make fun of it yeah
when it's a form of welcoming right
when uh miranda goes yes
[ __ ]
yes yo sucker decking
can you do can you do me and norman
can you do impressions about i did i did
one oh i only don't pick it up pick it
up that's all i do right
pick it up pick it up hey pick it up you
know that and yours was i did one i was
like ah there's a girl i went out for a
girl
oh yeah that's good yeah i couldn't
believe it sam's a little more subtle
yeah i could i could do you on the mic i
think yeah yeah so hold on you got to
ruin your posture
i went on a date with this girl
[Laughter]
she wanted me to be pretty good that's
pretty good
not bad
but john mayer's going on nick
oh he let me kind of wrap it up
is there anything funny what the tell
goes that route
what's this attell used to do this man
this used to have me he's so [ __ ]
brilliant he goes he goes hey give it up
for artie fuqua
right he'll go right after moisha
[Laughter]
that is i mean the best funniest dude my
favorite joke bombs he goes we'll be
right back
you know what i love what it's all about
whatever city he's in he does that like
fake cop when he goes ann arbor michigan
you guys know how to party am i right
he goes you know what the funnest thing
about ohio is packing up and getting the
[ __ ] out of that
and i love when he he bombs he goes
i better turn this up to funny yeah
yeah yeah
exactly i need quick glass glass monkey
uh
who are there any other big comics you
can do
[ __ ] george wallace oh yeah you're like
that's a stupid guthrie i just want to
tell you guys man i really enjoy your
very talented boy
[Laughter]
so i'm free
and i'm going to find a [ __ ] to lock me
up
so my netflix special is going to be
called i don't know wow that's great
how about uh
he's just david can you do quinn
colin quinn he's tough or jay moore can
do a pretty good quiz not bad but i
always be like i'm [ __ ] finished
yeah i'm finished hey excuse me we don't
need to uh explain that to us
like you know we we say you don't rape
google girls listen i don't need you to
grab me in the middle of the mall
wow okay
i think we get what rate means
i'm [ __ ] finished jesus christ i mean
just just you know how about the guy
who's going to challenge you to a fight
in a karate tournament
can you do that we do this thank god
this makes me laugh when he does this
why he loves this [ __ ] he just does the
80s bullying
next time you're [ __ ] dead
i don't know why this makes him laugh
it's [ __ ] amazing right
it's perfect those dragons move
he got the girl like yeah yo i heard you
were talking to my girl
listen bro one more time you're cruising
for a bruise
put them in a body bag like come on josh
leave him alone yo shut your mouth
[Laughter]
oh that's great
but quinn said it best about stand up
you mentioned this earlier
comedy is the closest thing to justice
like you put jack nicholson on stage
he's beloved he's got the sunglasses
everybody loves him but after three
minutes you're like all right buddy yeah
you got to make us laugh done done
that's what i like even with the
institute i don't know how you all feel
about the instagram
comedian when i see people go
comedian that title yeah comedy needs to
be like the armed forces
right
[ __ ] yeah man i'm like branches
the green room
i've come into green rooms where there's
a comic i go uh and who are you
oh i'm a local comic i go are you on the
show no why are you in the green room oh
yeah that's pretty balls why are you
[ __ ] in the green room that's both
yeah that's not your weekend i don't
give a [ __ ] who you i don't care if you
won uh uh oh kansas city's greatest
funniest
[ __ ] out of here man yeah there's no
there's no pecking order you have to
have a peck it should be like the armed
forces if you're a cadet you don't talk
to a pr or a private you don't talk to a
general a certain way oh interesting it
should be like
you what unless they talk to you right
it's like if i say hey you you know
that's how we did it right bernie was
like you do five minutes get the [ __ ]
off stage that's it there you go
get off yeah stand by the bar you don't
walk into the [ __ ] green room because
you did five minutes yeah that's what i
think i think i heard
i think i had more
we had a lot of fear mark oh
yeah i think i think there there's a
lacking of that uh there's an
entitlement now for sure it's
entitlement because and that's just how
i feel like rap music it's just a lot of
bombs on a microphone yeah there's a lot
of them women and men and there's a lot
of foreigners that because hey i'm from
tibet i'm going to be a comedian
suck out here
you know what i mean i'm tibetan some
good names
that's a special get the [ __ ] out of
here but you can't even blame them
because they go on tick tock or whatever
and they make a million views enthusiasm
but the the the art form is hard man yes
and it takes years it's hard man i'm a
funny dude you guys are probably
naturally funny like me i was a funny
naturally funny guy but the craft i said
whoa
whoa it's a different thing there's the
craft [ __ ] how do i take this
raw [ __ ] and technologize it and make it
technical right
not just well the way you're funding
your friends is different than the way
you're funny to a room full of strangers
you have to you have to hone that you
want it you want to hone it to where you
look like you're funny to your friends
again yeah you go to strangers you know
what i mean you want to just be like yo
man you just up there i go i'm just up
there this is thousands of hours
yes trial and error trial and error
different than martial arts i remember
when we would do martial arts at the
beginning you're doing all these
dumb ass punches and [ __ ] hundreds of
them honey right you're like what the
[ __ ] is this for
five ten years later you're like you're
like and you're like oh
right it's automatic oh it makes oh i
see comedy it's like limp dick [ __ ]
yeah yeah
oh yeah
but it's fundamentals it's like i watch
mma and yeah they just look like they're
[ __ ] throwing up but it's all it's
years
years of that technique yeah years of
that weighted grab they have to do that
over and over even if you want a sports
center you're like that's a skill they
acquired they made they're making this
look easy like so you think you could
just be like next coming up right that's
a skill yes yes catching the football
throwing the football the basketball the
shots that are going on that's you know
how many times they've done that harry
irving put like english on a ball
yeah that that goes in because he
practiced that
boom the way it hits off the ba it's tim
duncan when he would do that baseline
off
it's done thousands of times and i and
comedy to me is a sport it's physical
you got to get up there you got to show
up to practice it's no different than
sports you're a sports guy we're sports
people you have to show up some of these
[ __ ] think they're magical yeah
like they're just going to get lucky
because they're just so quirky and
you're smarter than that i don't write
any jokes but i put on this sweater and
i feel pretty good about it right so i
don't know it takes a lot of effort to
be effortless
it's real [ __ ] and it's like and and
like i said i don't know every con i
don't care but
that never changes the fundamental and
now i remember i was i was having a
conversation with sam j and she you know
she was she was getting her she drinking
couple of drinks to put him back and she
was like
she goes i'm telling you godfrey watch
there's gonna be a comedian
watch and that maybe not our generation
that's going to be able to skip the the
fundamental price said uh uh
that ain't going to change nobody's
going to steal i think she's right i
mean like with no no
as far as being good at comedy
wise they'll skip but not talking about
right skill wise i'm not talking about
getting on that's the difference in
sports [ __ ] five-year-olds
there's no basketball player here like
he's good on tick-tock so we're going to
sign him we were ten days
later he said that they're gonna be able
to skip
levels
because
of i said well they will skip levels
they just won't be good i mean what she
said they're going to have to be working
she said they're going to be good
without the hours they go now
it's not going to happen it's not going
to i'm telling you and i'm telling you
um
i was a funny guy before this [ __ ] i was
funny just a funny [ __ ] but i
had to work hard to get an act i had to
work you're a road dog and you're also a
dude when i go to clubs and i'm not
blowing smoke up your ass here
you do that when i play clubs i will the
staff will be like he did a different
hour every show and i'm like [ __ ] him
you make us look bad the waitress is
like oh we had godfrey last week he
juggled three chairs like what the [ __ ]
i can't do that
i'm just doing jokes about whatever
juggle you know i've given up yeah i'm
just kidding but you know it's always
three different hours uh he talked about
the city for 20 minutes i'm like oh [ __ ]
i got one line on the city yeah i'm like
san francisco falling off like [ __ ]
nothing all right
all right now what am i prepared right
here let's update this girl
let's go to this dating this girl
[Laughter]
every time i go to a club we had godfrey
last week different hour every time new
jokes every night [ __ ] with the hoes
[ __ ] with the crowd [ __ ] with the
city you're like god damn i yeah i i
just i mean what i do you know what i do
one of the things i do
in comedy [ __ ] with cities i go i google
when they were established
i do like baltimore is the best because
i'll do baltimore there's the there's
what club do you do in baltimore i do i
do my goobies i'm back to magooby's
timonium right in timonium but now i
just want to do the the comedy factory
which i did for like eight years it's
urban yeah very black and i but i do
this joker i go baltimore say 80 black
but named after a white man with a cape
it's like lord baltimore and everybody's
like yeah that's true man i said imagine
if he came back to see what happened to
his city
and they'd [ __ ] die
and he said
sire sire you have to come back look at
your city what do you mean
you're like oh my god what does oh black
people are going up see that's you built
a whole little world out of it what just
happened
and then people like yo man who the [ __ ]
are you it's like coming out on that
game
and there's just way just
different angles i mean sometimes google
google the city google some [ __ ] for
sure they [ __ ] when you do that they
go
you put a little effort into the show
make it a little special a long way what
are your favorite cities to play other
than like new york chicago you know
what's weird i i i like because if
you're funny
yeah yeah
like cities you're like i just i love
you i love houston houston yeah i love
that i love texas cities i love doing
mexico texas day dallas
i love san antonio san antonio is great
texas loves performances they're not too
southern and they're not it's not too
hickish and it's kind of mod it's like a
mixture of international and that
southern field well houston has got all
the vietnamese now very diverse it's
very neutral yeah right and a lot of
stuff has come out of texas which people
don't understand whole foods starting in
austin whoa
austin texas
brothers yeah
oh jamie foxx jamie fight and also
[ __ ] six flags it was texas
a lot of stuff started in texas which
you think what yeah didn't start in new
york yeah it started a lot of stuff
started at texas texas a very strange my
sister lives in dallas she's been in
dallas 20 years my my nephew goes to u
of t my other nephew his brother's going
to texas tech and my niece is going to
probably go to a texas college too well
ended in texas
you know what i mean i've been to that
museum me too and i was like i don't
think he shot him from there ah the
depository [ __ ] i i think it's
[ __ ] because i was like how the [ __ ]
he get anyway how did [ __ ] his head go
back like that i think it was in the car
bro interesting i think it was from the
car
huh something cause it was just it was
just i mean it's a very it's mysterious
but i was looking and i go
it just didn't look right i just didn't
look what a weird president to just be
banging like hot actress chicks they
were mad can you picture biden like
banging emma stone
it's like [ __ ] weird he'd be [ __ ]
betty white or something to him that's
still young
my bride is not too bad folks listen
folks folks we have to feel in monroe
maryland but listen
he was banging monroe yeah that was joe
jackson
dimaggio's girl [ __ ] with the yankee
clipper baby was probably linked up and
i got a story about dimaggio yeah he's
probably
probably mafia people love dimaggio yeah
italian he's italian dude he was the
clipper dude the [ __ ] dude greatest
hitter of all time it's him and ted
williams and then he pissed off frank
sinatra when he he won illinois he
needed chicago illinois he needed that
state
and
sam giancana was like hey i can get you
that but you got to do me this favor uh
kennedy he told joe kennedy you gotta do
me this favor
you gotta you gotta tell robert to stay
the [ __ ] off the mafia
right he said
keep him off us man and he goes don't we
we're gonna do that don't worry just get
us illinois that'll help us win this ch
presidency so the mafia hooked him up
got him the [ __ ] presidency got him
illinois which he needed and then joe
goes [ __ ] those [ __ ] [ __ ] those
guidos we're out
damn so he had a lot of [ __ ] against him
this is a mob hit i think i i but but if
you watch the documentaries go man he
pissed this person he [ __ ] marilyn
rowe there was a lot i think there was a
lot of enemies
he was trying to be race relations and
that wasn't possible
and i think l i think lyndon baines
johnson had some [ __ ] to do with it too
it's so weird to have a a celebrity i
mean he was kind of the first celebrity
president and obama was kind of the
second one like it's weird to see obama
was cool clinton was cool too
but obama had doing a podcast with bruce
springsteen obama having this
i just want to see that like this you
know sometimes obama
i just i understand what you're saying
wow
this guy's doing the whole body i'm a
real big fan of your music i really wow
i think that uh born in the usa
that's a great song wow well i
appreciate you you know i mean sometimes
you know obama yeah i think your
presidency is pretty damn good okay what
about what what about if uh trump
started a podcast with ted nugent
cat scratch fever
very good very good but i really don't
need you on my podcast you're not that
great i think uh i think that ac dc way
better than you anger better guitarist
how is trump not starting a podcast oh
[Music]
very good podcast the best podcast
i'll be doing it once a month because
i'm not a loser
so this is going to be a great podcast
in fact i can't wait to have guests i
don't like trump i would listen to the
public i would i would listen to it
i just want to hear him do ads yeah i
got a good sheath sheath underwear she's
like this oh blue
very good tablets i never use
them blue natural bone
[Laughter]
very good underwear very good underwear
boy this is rolo where where are you
going to be you gotta need to yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah you guys when is this showing
probably coming out two weeks two weeks
damn sorry we do one a week what are you
doing uh
i think i'm gonna tell them about this
date this week
in two weeks what's what what would that
be what date would that be can i have an
estimated uh
the start of uh december
now beginning of december
oh maybe wait no you're right to a week
into december so the 10th
jesus okay cleveland improv
december december 10th you guys probably
do hilarities
yeah we hung out one time remember we
went to the hall of fame together you
did that was great it's fun right i had
so much fun with you december 10th
through the 12th
cleveland improv december 10th through
the 12th go see them cleveland improv
that's in the flats over there i love
cleveland man cleveland's cool man yeah
i got love for cleveland i have love for
cleveland
they're they're a hardcore city they
look cool they love their teams they
love they got great chinese food and
they [ __ ]
uh the rock and hall of fame is
incredible and superman was created in
cleveland really yeah the crew wasn't
superman the other writer was it crumb
who was it uh who's the writer
harry potter
harry po giamatti played american
splendor you know wow
yeah um
um yeah cleveland superman because they
have a superman little uh museum yeah at
the at the airport right you can see the
creation of superman underrated town
cleveland underrated town anywhere else
coming up oh yeah i got um
minnesota minnesota house of comedy for
new year's i'm december 30th
january 2nd house of comedy in the mall
of america
you know which is a you know house of
comedy great great franchise rick
bronson tammy bronson kick-ass franchise
um
december oh um albany new york i got the
funny bone in albany new york seventeen
they didn't do a good job there yeah
it's boring as [ __ ] all hell but i
love that i love the shows december 17th
and 18th albany new york [ __ ] and my
podcast which sam has done godfrey
it's cool man i like it it's with the
gas digital network with the j okay
holy [ __ ] oh yeah wow
[Laughter]
he doesn't rock fingerless gloves but
he's right right right wow man god damn
yeah i'm gonna rock those fingerless
gloves does this
know about this dude no i don't think so
i don't think they they do you think
they really look alike jiggles they were
brothers that's weird
it's kind of weird
but anyway uh yeah um in godfrey we
trust on the gas digital network you
guys should uh subscribe to it promo
code god forget a week for free and also
i i got my little reward for having over
a hundred thousand subscribers on
youtube i got my oh
nice the little they give you a plaque
what you know and it's if you're on
youtube just type it in godfrey we trust
and press the subscribe button he's
great on it man godfrey we love him i
mean we're grateful to have him on the
pods this is cool you're only our third
guest we were like we we we we tried and
we tried to get you sooner so
yeah
man this is this is good you got to be a
regular in here we love you yeah
how you guys do it i don't know hell
yeah
i was doing it it gets growing it's
really pretty new and it's still popping
it's popping right things are all right
can't complain people you can feel it
when you go oh yeah you'll get some
drunk people at the show is going oh we
might be drunk
pacino
yeah it's gonna be a lot of that
it'll be a miami improv uh addison
improv mcgoobies uh
sam and comedy club in richmond virginia
uh sacramento punchline more common
samurail.com
what are you doing miami miami's i think
this weekend december good luck that's a
that's a tough room is it poisonous oh
there's a bunch of hot spicy latina
[ __ ]
and uh they are in the 19th 11th of
december they're not yeah they're just
like they're all dolled up
wait this is boring yeah i got i got
gary
you'll get a great view of cleavage from
the stage yeah uh
milwaukee improv atlanta buckhead
theater charlotte comedy zone mark
ridley's comedy castle kansas city
improv yes and uh
some other stuff mark normancomedy.com
check it out oh yeah instagram comedian
godfrey says
godfrey and instagram and it's and guys
come to our shows man yes you want real
comedy [ __ ] pound for pound
real joke writing
see these [ __ ] they do it for
real it's real talk like thank you just
stop stop stop
seeing these popular whack [ __ ]
see the popular good ones hey popular
[ __ ] stop go see real [ __ ]
comedy yes yeah i love this shirt too
the carlin shirt oh man hell yeah my
favorites george
dude was grateful to have you on thank
you it was a fun app and uh this is a
classic hell yeah all right keep
drinking thanks guys praise allah later
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
you